I already know that this is not going to
take one day I was foolish
[Music]
hi I'm Alex so today I'm going to be
making a macaron
but not just any macaron I'm going to
try to make a giant one so a macaron is
a French meringue based cookie don't get
it twisted with a macaroon which is a
coconut cookie thought one like slipped
out really fast off to a great start
right okay so first I need to beat my
egg whites and I hope I don't get any
yolks or shells in this or else it's a
double yolk you know what double yolk is
supposed to be good luck so that's a
good side
where's a bad luck it's not bad right
gotta beat these egg whites I'm gonna
beat them until they form stiff peaks
and while I beat them I'm gonna start
adding some sugar a little at a time
so that would be a soft cake because it
kind of fell over
nice so next I have my powdered sugar
and superfan almond flour superfine
almond flour is really important because
you want a smooth oh man this is gonna
take a while like three hours later you
know I've decided to make a chocolate
cheesecake swirl flavored giant macaron
that is a mouthful of the title would be
really nice to have a bigger bowl so it
chunky lot which is great so now I'm
going to separate this batter into our
two bowls now I'm going to add two
tablespoons of cocoa powder to one of
the bowls so one thing we're already a
little worried about is that this batter
seems pretty lumpy I think due to the
the sides supposedly superfine almond
flour which clearly wasn't super fine so
I'm gonna put a little bit of chocolate
and I'm trying to stick it to like one
side of the back other side
I think it's too much chocolate and not
enough of the white got in there so I
might have to pick out a different
technique for that one trying to be as
steady handed as possible it's tough now
we need to tap it definitely wrong we
got like a little bit of lift but not
enough also it just really so looks like
okay so I've thought about this recipe
some and I've decided that we're not
gonna do the chocolate swirl anymore
we're gonna make it pink so it'll be
really cute also I'm going to try to
eliminate some of the factors that I
know went wrong last time so I'm gonna
blend up the almond flour to try to make
it super super fine because apparently
superfine isn't quite fine enough okay
so I read online that if you reach stiff
peaks you can turn the bowl upside down
on your head stop
Oh quick some pink always use gel food
coloring to not liquid oh that's like an
electric thing so the trick for this is
that we've incorporated a lot of air
into the egg whites and we want to
deflate that air act out this bowl is so
damn small for all this butter so I'm
just going around the sides of the bowl
and then scraping down this batter is
still too thick because it plops down
into the bowl another test is the figure
8 test if you can do a figure eight then
you're ready but I'm still kind of
falling short nope that was like a
figure three eight is also my favorite
number I'll have you know so last time I
did they did kind of like a swirl but
I'm gonna try to just pipe vertically it
looks kind of lame that like the trace
is there like okay I'm gonna try to just
add more to it
oh I really think that this is not
proper technique because I feel like
it's gonna make more of a lopsided
macaron this is not perfect I need to do
it again I'm gonna scrape it back in
it's like someone projectile vomited
pepto-bismol
[Music]
they set time to bake um so they didn't
work I don't really know what happened
they just look super crinkly on the top
and also they did expand a little so
they are now attached back to the
drawing board is what I hope is the
final day of this giant macaron which
has been a giant pain in my ass so my
new strategy is to make the circle I
draw smaller and to filled that
completely so when it does grow as it
sets hypothetically both would grow at
the same rate Wow
I think my theory actually is going to
work I should win like a Nobel Peace
Prize for this macaroon Peace Prize okay
spin it
[Music]
my last batch proved to me that a double
yolk is good left now I can finally move
on to the filling because we've got our
chefs thunder bakes it's like wet I
can't
[Music]
Oh No another thing that I've learned is
that it's super important to use a
kitchen scale to be precise with your
ingredients so I'm getting to 200 grams
of egg whites also another little tip is
to add some cream of tartar to your egg
whites this will help stabilize them you
can also add a pinch of salt my almond
flour is all kind of mixed in then I'm
gonna start doing in a macro nosh almost
just like scraping the bowl on the sides
and then pushing down with the spatula
what I would definitely 285 like you
definitely want to lower and do it for
her so cook it for like 30 ish minutes
give it a go with that leave it in the
oven for like an hour minimum I'm gonna
kind of dry out the best would be to
leave it overnight okay so it's been 35
minutes I'm gonna check it's looking
really good
cross my fingers that this is a success
so I hope it doesn't stick to the
parchment
I just want to peel it off easily I'm
doing it I literally think I've learned
more about baking making this one
macaron than I've ever in my life which
is good whew I think I might actually
cry with us as OMA
I swear this might be the hardest thing
I've ever done I have to say I really
doubted myself on this one but the proof
is in the macaron
[Music]
[Music]